So the answer is, it's a little bit of both.
It is a random process in the sense that we're modeling intertweet time as
a random variable and we're taking draws from that variable.
Now, if it was totally random,
we wouldn't be able to do any better than modeling it as an exponential process.
But of course, as we have just found out,
there are clearly features that are influencing this process.
Specifically, length of a tweet and mention distance.
How long it's been since this person has been mentioned by one of
his close friends.
So it's not as totally deterministic as a functional mapping.
But then on the other hand it's not just complete randomness.
But if I have to chose one or the other, yes is the best answer.